hello everyone and welcome to the last
match we'll be showing from round five
of this year's video World Cup to see
who will qualify for the quarterfinals
over defeated World Cup it's the only
Pony versus Gujarati and their fur their
two classical games ended in a draw
which means they go into tie breaks
they're two uh rapid games and those are
the two 25 minute rapid games have also
ended in a draw and now we are in the 10
minute Rapids territory and this is
where the fun really starts uh if they
do if they wrote this uh they go into
five minute Blitz Games and if they draw
the five minute Blitz Games they go into
three minute Blitz Games and then uh
well you all know what happens then then
it's Armageddon so let's check it out
this is the first game of the match Yani
pomishi has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to C4 uh Knight to F6 by
visit Knight to F3 we have Ponte E6 and
G3 uh countering the ajinkur defense
with uh the theme catering of the light
Square Bishop D5 and Bishop to G2 so
we're transposing into the neocatalin uh
the defense with onto D4 and castles we
have knighted the C6 and now Pawn to D3
with Bishop to C5 and now Knight beat to
D2 so nothing new here all been seen
before we have castles Knights the B3
attacking the bishop and the bishop goes
back Bishop D7 with E3 and now captures
and the uh on E3 with Bishop captures
and knights the G4 going after the
bishop and E3 so Bishop to C5 and we
have a trade of Bishops captors captures
and now Pawn to B6 chasing with the
knight from C5 and there are some games
where Knight the H4 was played also
Knights the B3 is a known but here we
have Knight the D2 and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game so of course the idea is that uh
he's not even the night is captured on
C5 then Nepal captures the knight in G4
and he keeps a better position so here
we have Knight G back to E5 and now
Knight C to B3 uh we have Bishop to V7
if it is also if you get to his light
Square bishop and now Pawn to D4 we have
Knight to G6 Rook to E1 and now Pawn to
A5 preparing Ponte A4 to chase away the
knight from B3 uh Knight to F3 and now
Pawn to A4 uh chasing away the Knight we
have Knight to C1 and now Pawn to A3
going after the B2 Pawn B3 and now Queen
to D6 developing the queen connecting
the Rooks and now what nepo needs to do
is play Knight to E2 uh you need to keep
defending your D4 Pawn but for some
reason uh probably nipple thought it was
possible he played Knight to D3 which
gives up the D4 Pawn for seemingly some
counter play but there really isn't any
so probably nipple thought that he
didn't need to calculate this that he
was perfectly fine and vid it said nope
I'm not going to trust you just because
you're strong I'm going to calculate and
try and punish you and he played Knight
captures on D4 and okay Knight captures
on D4 we have Bishop captures in G2
Knight captures on E6 so nipple will win
back his Pawn uh we have F characters
and E6 and now King captures and G2 so
it is equal material uh but uh he did
give Vivid the semi-open f file for his
rook and we have Rook 8 to d8 now
putting pressure on the Knight here Rook
the E3 defending while lifting the rook
and now Knight to E7 now going for F5 to
attack The Rook uh and nipple has to
play Queen to E2 but he played Queen to
G4 and now with its position is
completely winning but it's not that
easy to see why I didn't really decide
which positions I'm going to use for
pause the video moment in this video so
we could also make this one because I'm
gonna spoil it for you a little bit if
it missed it so you know having that in
mind tried to find a move that vidit
missed while I'll give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh taking down
a former World Series Championship
Challenger Jani pondichi and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen to C6 with check kind of
kind of weird that that winning move
would start with check but you know such
is the way of Chess uh the the problem
now is that you don't have Rook to F3
which is a crucial uh defensive move in
all the lines if Queen to F3 then The
Rook is pinned and you can just play
Rook captures on D3 so that's the
problem so what you would have to do
after this check is just move the king
and now comes Knight to F5 attacking The
Rook but now it's much much different
now Rook to F3 is met with Rook to D4
and the White Queen has nowhere to go as
the White Queen is stuck here guarding
the rokan F3 if Queen H5 just G6 and
that's pretty much it you can play one
more Moon Knight E5 attack the black
queen but then the queen to D6 now uh
both the Queen the Knight and the queen
are hanging and you have to give up the
Knight for two pawns here okay this
looks like it gives white some sort of
an attack but after Knight G7 and you're
just down a full piece so that's the
sorry so that's the problem why it's
completely winning but um after this
queen to G4 move with it did not find
this queen to C6 move he played Knight
to F5 first and it seems like uh a much
more subtle way of handling the position
you know you always know that it's
better to keep the the check for later
and just improve your position first but
here it just doesn't work because now
Rook to F3 is a valid defense and nepo
finds it of course the problem is now
Queen to C6 yes you are attacking The
Rook but you're not in time to capture
now nepo just plays Knight to E5 and
attacks with its queen queen back to A8
and now King to G1 just unpinning and
everything is perfectly fine we have
Rook to D4 attacking the queen so that
it basically finds all of the correct
moves that we've seen in the winning
line he just doesn't uh find the move
order in which to play them at Rook the
F4 we have Rook to D2 now this Rook is
incredibly strong and this A2 Pawn is a
permanent weakness uh Knight back to F3
attacks The Rook and Rook the B2 so
video of course Keeps The Rook on the
second rank Knight the G5 now going
after the E6 spawn and the video defense
Queen to C6 we have Rook to E1
uh putting pressure on these six sponsor
offering the A2 point for the E6 Pawn
but the video just defends at Rook to F6
and now Queen back to D1 with some ideas
of Queen to d8 and uh of course uh yeah
it's it's a very hard uh probably nepo
thought that if vidit captures an A2
then he's going to go Queen to d8 the
problem is H6 was played and here nepo
gave up on it but it's still possible
here a nipple could play Queen to d8
check and after Rook to fade look at
this queen captures an FH check King
captures Knight captures an E6 check
eliminating the defender of the Knight
and once the king moves you're gonna
capture the Knight as well and it's uh
objectively a draw but you know it's a
rapid a little time on the clock who
knows what would happen here you know
both both players can easily blunder
here to give you an example let's say of
course black will capture the pawn on A2
creating a past a pawn now Rook f8 check
and if King H7 what do you do if Rook to
F7 you attack the G7 Pawn there actually
is a defense here just Rook B2 and you
don't care about real characters on G7
because if you capture King h8 there's
no way to actually Checkmate the
blacking if you could somehow bring your
Rook over to d80 you're just not in time
because the Knight would be hanging and
if you try Rook captures on C7 just
Queen the E8 everything is defended and
of course the past eight Pawn will now
be winning so well it's a valid idea
yeah you can't just uh you know force
your way through Black's defenses so
instead Knight the E4 was played by nepo
attacking The Rook here Rook back to f8
we have Pawn to G4 and Knight to D6 and
here we have Rook captures and f8 King
characters and now while nepo should
play Knight to C3 he played Knight
captures on D6 and he gives Vivid the
upper hand Queen capture Sandy six and
now Queen to F3 with check King to E7
and now Queen to C3 going after the G7
Pawn King F7 Queen to F3 check sorry and
not a king f8 a king to F7 was played
Queen to F3 check King to E7 and queen
to C3 uh King to F7 and queen to F3
check but here with it declined the
repetition of course for those of you
who are maybe new to chess a three-fold
repetition will yield a draw so King to
G8 and now Rook to D1 attacks the black
queen queen to f8 uh very very precise
uh moving by village now if Queen moves
to a silly Square then just Queen
captures and F2 will result in Checkmate
a quick one so after Queen E3 just took
characters on A2 and now Nepal really
doesn't have all that much to play for
of course you could capture an E6 but
after King h8 again doesn't do all that
much so nepo goes all in he plays G5
with Queen to F5 another very very
precise move point is that after G
captures an H6 Queen G4 check picks up
the rook and D1 so of course nepo cannot
play that so Rook the d8 check was
played with King to H7 and now G
captures on H5 but now just Rook to A1
with check here forces uh with it forces
a queen trade King G2 and queen to G4
check only moves the block with the
queen queen to G3 and now finally Queen
captures on G3 and of course David knows
that his position is completely winning
but he played so many of these moves
being down
um more than a a minute on the clock so
it's very very instructive how he does
it age captures King captures and H6 now
Rook to A8 and of course on the E5 we
have Pawn to B4 Ponte A2 and now Pawn to
C5 nipple once the trade off as many
pawns as possible but if it plays it
correctly Pawn to B5 we have King to F3
now you can play something like King to
H3 if you ever allow one single check
let's say you play something still like
this then one check uh and the next move
you promote a queen uh the pawn to a
queen so King to F3 you have to hide
from all the checks and now King to G5
we have rooked the A7 going after the
pawn onto E4 with check again the pawn
cannot be captured because Rook to E1
check will uh allow uh to promote his
Pawn to a queen so nepo has to go back
and now King to F6 so with it playing
basically perfect moves here uh G4 and
now Pawn to G5 taking away any and all
Contra play from nepo Pawn to C6 but now
just King the E6 we have King to H2 uh
King to D5 Rook day six defending the
pawn but if it was never interested in
this Pawn he plays King to C4 and he was
in this position on move 60 that
yaniponishu resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once so you play a few more moves and
there really aren't any useful moves you
can play you can basically move the king
back and forth Just King B3 and after
something like it doesn't really matter
what king B2 will be played and now the
Rook can finally move and you will get a
queen into the game doesn't matter what
you play real captures on C7 Rook C1
you're gonna bring the Rook back and now
of course a queen comes into the game
real characters throw captures and well
when one side has a rook and the other
one doesn't uh objectively that's when
our analysis ends so that's what
happened in game one and game two is
also very very nice and very short so
I'm also going to show you that not
spoiled too quickly if an apple was able
to bounce back or not so let's see what
happened in game two uh this is our game
2 where vid it now has the white pieces
so let's check it out nepo needs the
bounce back with black in order to force
Blitz tie breaks so here I visit opened
with Pawn to D4 and what do you think
what nepo played he played Ponte F5 he
went for the Dodge defense and this is
also something that I discussed in the
Nakamura video where pregnant was
playing Nakamura he won in the first
game and then Nakamura just went for the
robot defense he didn't want to play
anything solid he just wanted to win
which is very much different than when
Magnus loses the game it doesn't matter
how hard you beat him next game you're
gonna have to beat him just as hard from
a solid opening in order to really beat
him but here nipple goes for the Dodge
with Ponte F5 and Bishop to G5 the
Hopton attack we have Pawn to H6 Bishop
to H4 and nipple goes Pawn to G5 and
what is this did vidit just blunder a
full piece well not really because if
Ponte F4 then Ponte E3 and visit will
just collect the pawn if you capture the
bishop of course it's Checkmate in one
so with it knows what he is doing Knight
to F6 by Nepal we have Pawn to E3 and
now Pawn to D6 with Knight to C3 onto C6
and now Pawn to H4
Rogue Jade by Nepal we have characters
captures and now Bishop to C4 very nice
rapid development by vidit and now there
are some games where E6 was played also
Rook the G7 is a normal but D5 is what
nepo chooses and it is now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game so
Bishop back to D3 and queen to B6 now
puts pressure on B2 but with it again
masterfully plays A3 invites nepo to
capture on B2 but of course he doesn't
if you do this then Knight to A4 is the
oldest Queen trap in the book The Queen
has no more squares uh so after A3 just
Bishop to E6 continuing development and
Knight to G to E2 with Knight B to B7
and pawn to B4 we have Bishop to G7 and
now Pawn to F3 controlling the center
also keeping uh this Knight at Bay on F6
and now of course you cannot Castle
Queen side if you Castle Queen side
Knight A4 again traps the queen as the
bishop controls the C7 Square so nipple
plays King to F7 it's a pretty weird
Square for the king but if anyone can do
it is more certainly unipomishi Knight
the A4 attacks the queen and like we've
said the only Square available now is
the d8 square C3 and now Pawn to B6 with
Queen to C2 now comes Rook to h8
offering a rock trade but the video just
plays Rook to F1 remember video does not
need to win this game he already won the
previous one now he only needs a draw to
eliminate Nepal and go into the
quarterfinals of defeated World Cup we
have Pawn to A5 challenging the B4 pawn
and pawn to B5 with it wants to open up
the position C captures Bishop captures
and now Knight to H5 attacking the
bishop here Bishop back to H2 and Bishop
to F6 now just keeping the position very
solid Rook to B1 and now Rook to A7 and
now a video goes for a central
breakthrough you could play E4 makes
sense as the king is on the f file that
it chooses to go Pawn to C for instead
as he doesn't like his backwards C3 Pawn
Knights the G7 we have C captures on D5
Bishop captures and now Bishop to G3
E6 adding more defense to the to the F5
pawn and now Knight eat the C3
and the bishop is attacked and nepo just
brings it back with Bishop T8 uh maybe a
more impressive try would be Pawn to F4
yeah it looks very strong and once the
bishop moves now you play F captures
Bishop captures and Rook to C7 uh maybe
would pose more problems for video but
okay Bishop to A8 was played now comes
Bishop to C4 uh putting uh the bishop on
the same diagonal as the king so if this
Knight moves you will have to worry
about moves like Queen captures and F5
so nipple strikes with Pawn to F4 with
Bishop to F2 and now Rook to H2 so with
the rook and H2 the pawn pulling
pressure the bishop and this beautiful
long diagonal uh nipple definitely has
some Dynamic counter play here with
Bishop to G1 uh Rook to C7 and now of
course nepo is hoping for Bishop
captures and Rook captures on C4 but
with it doesn't allow even that he plays
Knight to B5 attacks the rook and
defends the bishop and now nipple just
has to decide which way to go uh you
know what what hurts less uh so Rook the
H1 was blade and of course the video to
grabs the material rooked Bishop
captures on C7 Queen captures and Bishop
to F2 now offering a rook trade but nepo
cannot afford the trade he needs to go
for some sort of an attack here Rook the
C1 and now we have Queen to D6 with
Bishop to G1 again attacks The Rook Rook
to H1 and now he captures an F4 we have
G captures and F for n again Bishop F2
but it offers a rook trade and again
nepo declines this and now again Bishop
to G1 attacking the rule Bishop to B5 is
also very nice but Rook the H5 Here and
Now Knight back to C3
uh with some ideas of Knight that the B5
also the Knight can come to E4 to attack
the queen and Bishop uh so Knights to F5
and now we have Knight to B5 attacking
the the black queen so you don't have
time for Knights the E3 or Knight the G3
Queen to E7 and now the should be back
to D3 and here uh we have King to G7 now
uh there are a couple of uh very nice
moves here like you could play Knight to
E3 but uh I didn't then I just gets
eliminated and then Bishop G6 picks up a
full Rook so you don't have time for
that that's why uh King to G7 you
sidestep the light squares uh but now of
course the bishop to F2 they are keeping
an eye on both of these squares and now
again Rook to H2 Knight to E3 or G3 for
the moment just doesn't do all that much
uh Queen to C8 a very nice move
attacking the bishop here uh Rook the h8
forcing the queen back and the queen to
C7 now with some ideas of D5 and
breaking through the position uh as the
Knight here is just very very weak so
here we have Bishop to D5 uh bringing
the defender back now King to D2 he
wants to open up the defile with Bishop
captures on F5 uh sorry D file and then
put the Rook on E1 to really harass that
black queen uh Rook to H2 again I think
nipple played Rook to H2 like 10 times
already here uh Bishop captures on F5 e
captures and Rook after E1 attacking the
queen and you don't really have a good
Square for the queen so Bishop to E4 is
played trying trying anything here not
to not to lose the match but now that it
plays the absolute strongest move and
that is Knight to D6 not only
threatening the
uh well threatening a whole lot but the
real problem is if you play a silly move
then Knight captures an F5 check wins
the game this loses the queen uh either
directly or if you capture with the
bishop then Rook captures an E7 check
will blunder the queen so instead Queen
to E6 was played but now again F
characters on e4 Rook captures on G2 and
now Rook to G1 not allowing nippo to
have any attacker left we have F3 nipple
fighting creating creative ideas as
usual but it's just not enough in this
position Rook captures F captures and G2
and now Pawn to D5 and here you are just
out of squares Bishop to G5 check seems
seemingly connecting with the Rook
nicely but just King to E2 and he was in
this position and move 50 that Yani
pomishi resigned in the second game in a
row and it is vivid who goes into the
quarterfinals of defeated World Cup 2023
eliminating the former world champion at
Ian nipponishi now here you resign of
course uh your queen is hanging and you
don't have a good Square for your queen
because the queen also needs to guard
the Knight on D7 so what you could play
here uh really nothing if you move the
queen to E5 then you lose the Knight and
of course if Queen the E7 defending Then
I then you allow Knight captures on F5
check this loses the queen and of course
very very easily uh the game so very
very uh very impressive by Village
eliminating janiponishi everyone thought
okay we already have three Indians in
the quarterfinals no way we're gonna
have four I mean it's the only problem
who we are talking about who who won the
Kansas tournament twice in a row no way
if it beats him but that is exactly what
the video did he defeated the animation
and now uh sorry about that here uh here
is who is in the uh quarter finals of
the sorry about that this is a weird
looking uh we're looking table there we
go uh this is who is in the quarterfinal
so it will be gookish versus Magnus cost
and vidit will be facing ninjat abasov
who also had an incredibly incredible
tournament uh uh Dominguez Perez will be
facing Fabiano Corona and pragnan that
will be facing Arjun Eric Aces so uh
every match will be absolutely
incredible uh I hope we managed to cover
as much as possible and it's going to be
very very interesting so what does this
mean uh I mean what are the players
fighting for of course they are fighting
for him they are raiding they are
fighting for money but mostly they are
fighting at uh qualify for the Fida
candidates tournament and as the top
three contenders here will qualify for
the video candidates tournament uh you
know it's uh with every win the the
tension Rises and here they are very
everyone is very very close to
qualifying we still don't know if Magnus
will play because Magnus has a direct
entrance Into The Vedic handle this
tournament if he wants uh I mean he's
the highest rated player and the highest
rated player of January 2024 will be
considered the highest rated player to
enter the candidates tournament so if he
declines that then we go for to the next
in line which could be Fabi but Fabi
calls could also qualify still through
the uh through the Fida World Cup so
anything is still possible uh it's um
it's far too early to you know summarize
who for who it's possible to qualify and
not but with every uh every round of the
affiliate World Cup behind us we are
getting closer to that answer uh that's
the game or rather those were the games
hope you guys enjoyed that I would like
to thank uh Philip hexenberg Serena was
kashup E1 check
Ferris is the best wife and Yoon Yang
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
uh undefeated World Cup of course until
it finishes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and I see there's an extra e in
Philip there so I'm gonna fix that
before I actually ended the video uh
sorry about that there we go
would be weird to finish it like this
there we go all right moving the all
right there we have it uh see you soon